disney can't figure out how to do a
firefly reboot
welcome to scitrek your scifi tv a movie
channel
so
if you are regular to sidetrack you'll
know that i have a few sources in around
a few television studios now i have a
bit of a network and they feed me bits
of information now one of them was
talking to me about another tv show that
has been planned for a reboot while he
was telling me about this he happened to
slip in a little tidbit that i don't
think he actually meant to tell me
but
once i heard it i was not gonna let it
go this is all very doable
shouldn't be a problem at all
a few modifications
get some real maneuverability out of
this boat
what is the news
well disney now own the right to make
firefly they bought fox and they've
actually got firefly the series and
serenity the movie on disney plus now so
the person i talk to is on the creative
side of things and he gets to see little
bits of a lot of what's going on in a
couple of different studios
and he is telling me that he was
actually in a meeting um a couple of
months ago and they were talking about
the firefly reboot now i've talked to
you about firefly reboot a couple of
times and how disney had been planning
it and i know lots of other like
popcasts and other channels have done
the same
[Music]
the problem is that we've had no
official announcement and these rumors
have been knocking around for well over
a year
the reason why we haven't had any
official announcement according to my
source is that disney cannot figure out
what to do with the reboot
you paid money for this sir
on purpose
what
come on seriously zoey what do you think
honestly sir i think he got robbed
robbed what what do you mean
it's a piece of failure
they have written five pilots apparently
one uh an episode two were full hard
reboots so forget that the original
series ever happened and the other three
would be soft reboots where they were
bringing back one or two characters from
the original series my um source tells
me that dual state is the primary
candidate to return and there may have
even been initial conversations but that
is just a rumor i can't confirm it by
the way if you do like the content
please don't forget to like and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
you can also consider becoming a member
hit the join button that little bit of
contribution every month really helps us
to create more content so five pilots
all of them have been looked at by um
different executives within disney and
all of them have been scrapped very well
you get the perks got your own room
no
you share a book
that one
really
jane this ain't funny
yeah i ain't laughing you move on over
to this side
we'll not only show you where the
stuff's at we'll see you get your fair
share
i know sad seven
private room
your own room full run of the kitchen
whole shot
game
there were rumors a few months ago this
was pushed mostly by the popcast youtube
channel that actually john favreau was
involved in the development of the new
firefly reboot now i pooh-poohed that
completely when i heard that rumor i
said what a load of rubbish
but it turns out it's kind of true not
quite true but kind of true john favreau
apparently has been brought in as a
consultant to speak to the people that
are trying to put this project together
and he was very clear and to say that
the five proposals so far of that way
that they should reboot this tv show
none of them work
and he really is i think um in a very
good position at disney that whatever he
says they will listen to so what does
this mean for any firefly reboot at the
moment and do we even want to see a
firefly reboot
personally firefly is one of those shows
that i love
it it's up there with my favorites and
mainly because it was taken away from us
too soon but also because two or three
of the episodes of firefly are just
perfect
they're perfectly rounded episodes out
of gas jumps to mind in particular as a
perfect episode
if this show is going to come back i
would absolutely adore to see it but
there is a massive risk
because the tv show was very much
character driven nathan fillion was a
big part of that alan tudyk was a big
part of that and without them and
without characters like jane who i don't
know whether he would return or not
i'm not sure it would work they did
really have lightning in a bottle in a
tv show that in lots of ways shouldn't
have worked i should also point out that
this source is the person that told me
that the plan was for tim munir to be
the showrunner and he said that is still
potentially the plan tim bernier is
still very much involved in this he is
managing he hasn't written any episodes
that um my source is aware of um but he
is very much acting as a consultant and
as a
the plan basically is that he will
become the show runner but until i think
it's greenlit anything contracts are
written it's very informal at the moment
my source also tells me though that john
favreau will not actually have any
direct influence on the tv show if it is
made that his consultancy is just a
temporary thing and they brought him in
really um because well one he apparently
does love the show and as soon as they
said would you like to he just jumped at
the chance but it was uh look we're
having a problem with this we can't
figure it out if you've got any ideas
that was kind of the
way around and john favre just went to
three or four meetings and that was the
um most of his influence on the matter
and there are no plans to bring him back
for any other conversations um he is
very busy with other projects
so what does this mean for a firefly
reboot
it basically means that it's not going
to happen anytime soon they have
absolutely no idea what to do this
franchise even though they would love to
give it a go because
as actually my source said that in one
meeting an executive got hold of the
numbers for how many people have watched
the firefly series on disney plus and he
thought the figure viewing figures were
wrong because they were so high
a lot of people have watched firefly on
disney um because it's the first time
it's been on a streaming service for a
long time and i've absolutely i've
watched it three times myself
so disney really really want to make
this show because
you only have to go on facebook and look
at firefly fan pages let's say that five
times quickly um to see how much
interest there still is in the show
disney are very good at squeezing every
last drop of blood out of every
franchise they own so i absolutely
certain that this will become a reality
at some point soon
but i do think that it will be firefly
by name only it will be nothing like the
original it will be set in the same
universe i hope for a soft reboot with
loads of new stores because at the end
of the day it's a big universe there are
lots of stories to tell
um but i like i say firefly by name only
this is not going to be a continuation
of any story we've seen already
so right smart purchase this vessel
i tell you what
you buy this ship
treat her proper
she'll be with you for the rest of your
life
son
hey son
you hear a word i've been saying
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you enjoy the content consider
becoming a fully fledged sidetracker hit
that join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time they know there's an
appetite for it you only have to go on
facebook or whatever else and look at oh
you only have to go on facebook twitter
whatever else and look at firefly fan
page
you only have to go on facebook and look
at firefight
already
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out and please if you
enjoy the content be cool
and please if you become ah
so if you're new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell
serenity and firefly if we're talking
about reboost would you would you you've
been asked a million times but would you
do that why wouldn't i do that it was
one of the best things that ever
happened to me now let me ask you
because i've read an article or
something that says you know this was
the best acting job i've ever had i
think that was for firefly
or maybe yesterday
yes at the time yeah
right yes
but my question is and you could just
divert if you want
what if they do these projects without
joss whedon
oh that would be heartbreak
because he created them yeah those are
those are his
how can you
how would you well because of all the
controversy and all the stuff that
happened
what's your take on that or would you
rather not speak
i just wonder correct me listen i
i read that article yes um
nowhere in there at any point in time
did he mention
firefly
i
you know i
i hadn't entirely that was not my
experience with that man
what was your experience
funny
self-deprecating
incredibly talented
maybe a little haunted
i mean right listen by his own admission
that guy's a work in progress and i
appreciate that
um
i would work with josh again in a second
i would work with him again in a second
and has he ever hinted about doing one
of these projects again
nathan
i mean how do you feel about uh
we we talk we joke we we fantasize if i
if i say anything too solid it'll go
crazy i mean i hate being responsible
for that crap but
yeah but
that's
an entire cast and crew of people who
had a fantastic job on that job it was
short-lived so it was
it didn't have an opportunity to decide
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play join tom
welling and mike the ultimate small the
fan base is remarkable so it did have
legs i was surprised
at how we were treated i was surprised
at how it ended i kept saying guys don't
worry
we're telling great stories people love
it's a good show we're doing everything
right don't worry and then you cancel
that's like one hour later heartbreaking
oh my gosh yes oh my god it was terrible
and then this whole
fan base i mean a huge fan base you go
to cons how many people what percentage
want to talk about serenity or firefly
you know i'll tell you i i couldn't i
mean
at this point you have so many projects
people really rarely go to just the one
so they'll list off a bunch but i'll to
that i'll say this i used to be able to
spot a firefly fan
i used to say oh
is it the shirt
is the uniform typically a generational
thing uh yeah you you think you would
know
and uh
that's now a thing of the past i no
longer have that gauge where i can say
oh that's a castle fan and that's a
fireplace fan
[Music]
you